Hello legends. In this video, we're
going to be diving into the new Claude
Opus 4.6 and we'll be explicitly
exploring the new agent teams. So, I'm
going to be running an experiment in
this video where I'm going to be
spooling up a Claude code instance using
the Opus 4.6 model, getting one agent to
build out a certain project for us, and
then I'm going to be spooling up another
Cloud Code instance, enabling the agent
teams mode, then giving the exact same
prompt, and then comparing the results.
So I want to quickly touch on the
anatomy of an agent team versus what we
previously had which was a sub agent. So
sub aents work by receiving a very
specific prompt. Then that prompt is
actioned and completed and then only the
results of the completion are shared
back with the main context window.
Whereas agent teams are a little bit
more sophisticated. So when we enable
the agent team, we actually first pull
up a team lead that manages a number of
different prompts depending what kind of
tasks we need to complete. The team
leader will then distribute those
prompts amongst very specialized
teammates and all of these teammates
actually spool up their own instance of
clawed code. So this is important to
note because uh sub agents actually work
within the one instance or the one
session but then each of these guys
actually runs in their own isolated and
dedicated session. So the sub agent
there is uh lower token consumption and
technically speaking a lower quality of
output. They're meant to be used for
like simpler tasks. But when you're
using an agent team because they have
their own instance, they can actually
use a lot more tokens and they can run
more independently. Now the interesting
thing is that all these guys can
actually speak between each other. So if
teammate A is working on the front end,
teammate B is working on the back end.
If teammate A gets stuck, they can
directly communicate with team A B to
kind of get unstuck or to try and figure
things out and they can keep
communicating back and forth between the
team lead and then the teammate. Whereas
in this instance, you'd spool up the sub
agent that would complete the task and
then communicate it back and if they had
to do another run at completing a
specific part of work, it wouldn't
actually be a direct communication. It
would just kind of be very transactional
in nature. And then the final
interesting thing is that we can
actually speak to any one of the team
members at any time. So when we're in
the cloud code terminal, we'll see later
on that we actually have access to
toggle between the team leader and any
of the open teammates and just
communicate with them directly. So we
can change their scope of work, get
feedback on their working, what what
they're working on, and even try and
unblock them if they get stuck.
Anthropic summarizes the difference
really well over here where they say sub
agents are better at working out
smaller, more focused tasks, and then
agent teams are better at figuring out
complex problems where they can
collaborate together. So here's a really
good example of when you would actually
fire off an agent team. So if you want
to review a code base, typically when
you just issue one agent that task,
they'll latch on to one theme or one key
area and then struggle to actually
diversify their approach. Whereas if you
have an agent team, you can give each of
those members in a team a different
distinct area to focus on. Therefore,
each of these areas will get an
appropriate coverage from each agent.
And the second example from anthropic is
in a very similar light where if you
want to understand a complex issue,
typically one agent would again just
find one possible explanation, one key
theme, latch on to it. So then you
actually want to prompt up an agent team
and then give different members of the
team distinct areas to explore and to
look at. So I've got two instances of
cursor open up. I've got a normal
instance where I'll just be using one
agent to build out this prompt for us
and then another instance where I'll be
spooling up an agent team and giving it
the exact same prompt. So I'm just
spooling up the very first instance
using this single agent. I'm asking it
to build me a very basic task manager
app as a single page web application. So
it's nothing fancy. It's just enough for
us to test this out and see what
happens. So now in our next terminal, in
order for us to set this up, we first
have to initialize agent teams. So to
enable agent teams, we have to go into
our settings.json file and then add this
environment variable, which is claude
code experimental, and then toggle it to
equal one. So just before we do that,
make sure that you're running the latest
version of claude code. And you can just
check which models you have available to
you by going into forward slashmodel.
And once you get into here, you got two
different options for an Opus 4.6 model.
You have the regular Opus 4.6. Then you
also have the 1 million token context
4.6, which is better for those longer
sessions and more complex tasks. If you
toggle with your keyboard left and
right, you'll also see that on the very
bottom, you can toggle your reasoning
effort. So you go low effort,
mid-effort, and then high effort, where
high effort basically uses unrestricted
amount of tokens, which will give you
better results for more complex tasks
and bigger project builds. I'm going to
leave mine on low effort and just going
to use the regular Opus 4.6 model. And
I'm going to ask Claude Code to
initialize the uh basically change the
settings for me so we can initialize
agent teams. So Claude's found that
file. Let's just give it permissions for
the session. And it's identified the
change that it has to make. So, it's
going to be adding exactly what we had
in the instructions. So, I'm going to go
yes once again and done. Looks like
Claude Code has made that change for us
in the settings.json file. Now,
important to note, we cannot start an
agent team in this specific session. We
have to restart Claude Code. So, to do
that, you can just go into plus and then
go into a new terminal, restart Claude
Code here. And now Claude will be able
to access the agent teams. So it's
important to note when we want to
initialize a new agent team at the
prompt level. We have to explicitly give
those instructions to cloud code we have
to say create an agent team to XY Z to
complete some kind of task or project
for us. And here is our prompt. So
create an agent team to build out the
following for us. And this is the exact
same prompt that we gave to the very
first instance on cursor where we had
just a single agent working for working
on this project. So here we are. Cloud
code is immediately telling us I'll
create a team to build out this task
manager app in parallel. let me set up
the team and then break down the work.
So, we'll first be building out the plan
of what we need built and then we'll be
assigning each of those items from the
plan to a separate agent on our team.
So, now we're sporting up the teammates
for each task that we created. So, the
first task is to create the HTML and
CSS. So, the UI builder is going to be
working on the HTML and CSS. Once that's
done, I'll spawn up the JS developer to
add the application logic. Let me wait
for the first task to complete. So,
after each task was defined, then Claude
Code was able to spin up the teammates.
So, it span up the very first teammate
which is building out the uh looks like
the front end, the HTML and CSS. And
then on the bottom over here, we can see
that there's two teammate agents already
deployed. We have the main agent, which
is the person that's the actual team
lead. And then we have the UI builder
agent. And if I hold shift and I press
up and down arrows, I can see that I
have access to the team lead to speak
with them directly. And if I press shift
and then down, I have the UI builder.
Now, in this instance, the app is pretty
simple, but I've actually built out a
couple of apps where there's three
agents working in parallel. Let me just
click yes for these edits. And then I
actually have options of three different
agents that I can speak with at one
time. And sometimes during the course of
the project, you'll actually find that
once one specific component is finished
and the feedback goes back to the team
lead, the team lead will create some new
project and actually spin up new agents
to work on the next part of the build.
So, it gets pretty advanced and it's
also really fun to see. There we go. So,
we're actually spinning up different
agents now. So task one assigned to the
UI builder. Build the HTML structure and
CSS theming. Create the foundational
HTML structure. We've got a skeleton
given to it. And actually a very clear
set of instructions for this builder.
And now we can see down below if I hold
down shift and I toggle up and down,
we've got the team lead just as before.
Then we have the JavaScript dev, which
is the new agent that was just created.
And then we have the UI builder. Coming
back to our first agent, let's just
click accept on these permissions. Oh,
and there we go. It's actually just
finished now. Let's pull this up. Okay,
so this looks really cool. We have views
on our side, due date, priority,
projects. We also have toggle for night
mode and day mode. Let's create a new
task. So, cook
dinner. Leave the description empty. We
pop up a little calendar. That's
awesome. Subtasks. Even subtasks. That's
cool. So, buy food. Let's hit enter.
All right. Just click new subtask, cook
food, and then a new one, eat food. So
that's interesting. It's like a layered,
it's like a folder. It's like a layered
task. Typically, like from demo task
managers that I've built, it's usually
one top layer and then you just click
close in a top layer. But now you have
little subtasks, which is what a lot of
actual like ClickUp like actual task
managers do. They'll have subtasks
within a task. So that's really
interesting. We have active task
completed. So, if I actually just click
one, two, and if I click this cook
dinner, and it goes into the completed
view. That's nice. And let me just see
if I right click on here. Okay, we have
edit, reopen. Wow, this functionality is
actually insane. I actually I can't
believe that I can change priority by
doing the right click on here. Move to
inbox, move to work, move to personal.
Okay, so we have different views over
here. So, personal view shows that
project. Let's move it across to inbox
now.
and it moves. This is beautiful. This is
really nice. This is Opus 4.6 on its
own. And that is very impressive. And if
we delete that and let's go to create a
new project as well. I'm going to call
this dinner. Let's click enter. There we
go. So, as this stands, this is actually
very impressive. It's It looks really
good. It doesn't look like it's been
made by a botch AI like a lot of the
older apps that we've been building
across the last few months. And on top
of that, this is usable. It's
immediately usable. The functionality is
very easy, very smooth to use. And it
gave us a bunch of different sections,
due dates, priorities, and projects as a
starting point. This is fantastic. You
could literally use this to run your
personal life without buying another
tool. So now back in the agent team, we
see there was a shutdown request because
all the tasks were completed. Let's fire
this off and see how it looks. Okay, so
this looks really interesting. The first
thing I want to note is that the name
was the exact same as that first version
from the single agent task flow.
Otherwise, this looks a lot more
polished. We have the night mode and day
mode with a bit more of a transition
between both. Let's add a task here.
What needs to be done? Cook dinner.
Leave the description for now. We can
choose the date. So, looks like the date
creation function or the task creation
functionality is very similar. Oh, we've
got subtasks here as well. So, by food,
add a new one. Cooked food. And if I hit
enter, okay, just creates the task.
Nice. Let's actually go back to edit
this and have one more. Eat food. We
can't forget about eating the food. Save
the task. If I click on write. Okay. So,
our options here are a little bit
different. We can edit the task,
duplicate, or move it to a different
section. And we can just choose numbers
here. So, that navigation panel is a
little bit different. If I just come
back into here and quickly create a an
eat food task and I create this. If I do
the right click here, I've got a lot
more of a navigation panel. So, this is
yeah, it looks a little bit more like
less polished, less refined, but it is
in my opinion for me a bit more usable
cuz I just like having everything easy
access here. But you can definitely see
like this side panel over here, it does
look a like a lot more polished. So, I'm
just going to quickly flip across for
both. This is that single agent one.
We're using more of these emojis. We
could definitely go back and refine this
and say don't use the emojis, but I do
like how it's more filled out over here.
But then the agent team one does look a
lot more refined. So I actually like the
side panel here. It's very nice. We
didn't have the settings panel in the
first version. But if I click this, it
doesn't actually go anywhere. And if I
go onto board view, it doesn't go
anywhere as well. So I'm just going to
come back to the agent team. I'm going
to click escape to return to the team
lead. I'm just going to say, can you
confirm the JavaScript is working
because some of the buttons which was
settings or board view, they don't work.
So, let's see what happens when we uh
when we try and fix this. So, there we
go. Looks like we have a fix. Now, the
board view and the settings buttons uh
will actually do something. So, now
coming back to our task manager, if I
click on board view, nice. Actually,
looks like we can drag and drop between
here as well. So the board view now
works and it changes the status as we
drag it to a different section of our
pipeline between urgent to high to
medium. It actually applies that to the
task as well. And now let's check out
the settings panel. So over here we have
light mode or dark mode. Okay, default
view and then we have export data as
JSON or import and then clear all data.
So now to do a postmortem between both
builds either using the single agent or
the team of agents. The single agent
took 6 minutes and 55 seconds to build
out the task manager. And I actually
like how this looks more than the agent
team app. I like that they're using
emojis over here. It's a bit more fun.
It makes me want to create tasks and
follow through with them. And then
looking at the agent team, the first
part of the build was actually a little
bit faster. So it was 4 minutes and 50
seconds versus 6 minutes and 50 seconds.
So 2 minutes faster. But then we had to
come back and rework the canban board
button and also the settings button. And
that added an additional one and a half
minutes to our build time. So I would
say the build time is like for like. And
in this portal, while I don't
necessarily like the UI as much as the
first one, I could definitely fix it by
prompting up. I do like that it went a
little bit deeper and it had the board
view. And I do like the settings panel.
So I didn't even prompt up that I wanted
a settings panel. And I didn't even
think of having an export or an import
functionality to take tasks between
workspaces. So I've been testing the new
Claude Opus 4.6 the six model on some
other projects that I've been building.
I ended up building a like a car
dealership portal that runs tasks. It
has a database on Superbase. I installed
the Superbase MCP into the 4.6 model and
was able to integrate the database for
authentication and start building a bit
of the backend so it can actually create
customers, create tasks and jobs and all
this stuff. So, that was very
interesting. If you guys want to see
more of an advanced build, please let me
know in the comments. Thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next